well in the book smart money smart kids
that my daughter Rachel Cruz and I did
together became a number one New York
Times bestseller um one of the things we
talked about in that book is work when
it comes to how to teach your kids how
to handle money one of your jobs as a
parent is to teach your child work teach
them work ethic to be able to tie down
and understand that money comes from
work your dad your mom are not an ATM
they don't just produce cash they're not
Fort Knox and that's what caught you
think when ki little kids think that or
big kids think that that's when they
hear mom and dad say things like money
doesn't grow on trees your parents are
say that when money doesn't grow on
trees to which people started making
money trees as a result I mean you know
it's just really it's a very real thing
but you know I am learning as I think
back through our kids growing up and now
grandkids and looking and dealing with a
whole lot of 20-somethings on my team
that are phenomenal people and very
bright and have great work ethic you
know I read an article the other day
that this this millennial generation is
worthless and all that and I got to tell
you there's a percentage of every
generation that's worthless and there's
a percentage of every generation that's
awesome and it just maybe with ones
you're coming in contact with I'm hiring
a whole bunch of folks in their 20s and
I'm finding awesome people now we we
have to screen through the crazies that
are out there I mean they come in here
with all kinds of you know weird ways of
looking at life and we don't want to
deal with all that stuff but then what
doesn't know how to work and let me tell
you work is not just showing up and it's
not just it's how you view it like do
you work while you're at work and you
know the way I think about is this and
you know I'm kind of old school and I'm
kind of dinosaur I'm kind of primitive
but do they dig out the roots of the
dandy
mine or do they cut the top off of it
now if you've ever had a dandy line in
your yard and it grows up you know the
whole top of the thing is little seed
pods right and so soon as you run over
it with a lawn mower your turn one down
the line into five hundred that's just
what happens immediately and so if you
don't want a yard full of freaking weeds
then you you don't cut a dandelion you
dig out the roots and I don't know what
the technical name for that little tool
is with a little fork on the end of it
but you can little hand tool you can buy
it at Home Depot or Lowe's or whatever I
always called it a dandelion fork now I
discovered the dandelion fork when I was
about ten twelve years old and I was
cutting grass in the neighborhood and I
worked for this man named mr. Carnahan
and I kid you not his nickname was
slugger now you may not believe this but
it's the truth
Slugger Carnahan now mr. Carnahan did
not like dandelions at all and he didn't
want any 12 year old kid cutting his
grass for $3 a pop boy was I getting
rich there and he want me cutting grass
and spreading dandelion seed all over
the place so if you were going to work
for Slugger Carnahan you had to have a
deadline fork in your pocket and you
stopped a lot more when you come up to
the dandy line you could still be
running but you don't run over it and
you step in front of it and you do the
work properly which is dig the Danny
line out by the roots now I think a lot
of you know that some of you don't but
how does that apply to your work because
see you can mow the grass and knock the
top off at anyone and it looks like
exactly the same as if you dig that any
line out by the roots when you finish
the job it looks exactly the same but
you and I know you didn't do it right
because you're going to have a yard
that's a mess at the end of the summer
full of weeds because you're spreading
the seeds of the weeds all over the
place
so you cut the top off rather than doing
it right are you cutting the top off see
that's not real work that's almost like
getting paid for the wrong things isn't
it and I you know I guess probably for
some people I'm slugger Carnahan because
I got no tolerance for people who won't
dig the stuff out by the roots we we
believe in excellence around here man
I mean doing it right that's the kind of
work that's real work because it works
on the short-term the yard looks good
and it works on the long-term the yard
looks better and you don't have to have
a continuous fight with weeds in your
business in your life in your career in
your marriage because weeds are
everywhere in our lives they're
delivered to us on the internet they're
delivered to us by Twitter and by
Facebook they're delivered to us in the
mailbox they're delivered to us by five
million commercials over the television
show that we should have been watching
in the first place because it was trash
to start with they're delivered to us in
the newspaper they're delivered weeds
are air people your friends will bring
you weeds and thought they were been
friendly weeds are everywhere in our
lives
and yet don't we stand back in
admiration and in honestly a little bit
of all and wonder with the man of the
woman who has taken the time to make
sure that not only are the weeds cut but
the dug out by the roots the weeds in my
life are not just cut off to where they
look good from the outside where the
outside world looking in feels like oh
they've got it together but no by God
they got it together all the way down
it's real character it's not a facade
you know the Millennial is one of the
words they use for that kind of stuff is
so-and-so is authentic they're authentic
translation they're not fake translation
they're not a freakin hypocrite
they're real all the way through is your
work real all the way through if you
owned a business would you be glad you
worked there doing work the way you do
your work is that the kind of work
you're doing are you that proud of not
only what you do but how you do it and
why you do it and the level of passion
and excellence that goes with that let
me tell you if you do that and you show
up five minutes early and you leave five
minutes late and you work while you're
at work and you smile while you're there
there is no stopping your career you
know why you got no competition because
nobody does that
you're as rare as a freakin unicorn it's
amazing
so do your work as under the Lord do
your work with an extreme level of
passion and excellence walk around with
a dandelion fork in your pocket people
this is the Dave Ramsey show
you